why are you taking this off the menu
taco bell why
taco bell has been there for me when no
one else has
growing up we would always skip class go
to taco bell
and just hang out and eat like
ridiculous amounts of food so pretty
much
i'm a huge taco bell fan this is
probably the earliest i've ever had taco
bell
i usually go at 2 a.m but since there's
only a couple days left before taco bell
actually discontinues a bunch of stuff
i'm gonna be trying as many as i can and
i don't know
a how my stomach is gonna handle it be
how my butthole is gonna handle it
because you know that's gonna be a
disaster
you wanna talk about what's it's gonna
talk about there she is in
all her glory okay we are pulling up
to the taco bell all right i may just be
like the most impatient person alive but
something about waiting in a
drive-through just
hits different hey how's it going um
there's like a bunch of items
that are getting discontinued soon right
yeah can i get
all of those can i get um the mini
skillet bowl
but with no cheese and no sour cream and
then
can i do the nacho supreme
[Music]
and then can i also just get like a
bunch of sauce
[Music]
okay
we got the goods look at all of this
so this one is i know for a fact the
beefy fritos because you open it
we got fritos in there it's pretty
amazing
this cheese is insane beefy frito
crunchiness
i like the fritos crunch can you blame
me we have
the spicy potato taco i don't usually
get the potatoes i know a lot of my
vegetarian vegan friends like potato
shout out me
as a vegan myself this vegetarian option
being available
to not just be beans like a lot of
lettuce a lot of potatoes i'm gonna take
some lettuce out because honestly i
don't really like lettuce that much
am i only beef with taco bell is that
like
the majority of their burritos are like
salad
it's so good it doesn't need to be that
good but it's so good
potatoes are good i don't really like
this one seven layer burrito
oh wow the glock the rice the tomato
sauce oh
the lettuce apparently she said hi i'm
here and here we go
put some fire sauce on it you know as
you should let's get it nothing
affordable
this one is like feels so much more
fresh than some of their other stuff
this is like what i get when i go to
talk about not inebriated
not a big fan of seven layer burrito a
lot going on in there but
i won't miss that one
with the grill tortilla she's gonna be
good look at her
wow this is so good so my i think one of
my favorites also
i just love the spiciness to it and they
have little like they're like spicy
fritos
i don't know if that's actually what
they put in them but that's what they
look like something so
simple but so beautiful
it's so good why are you taking this off
the menu taco bell why
are we got the nacho supreme and the
triple a or nachos both sound pretty
supreme to me
the difference i can notice between this
one this one this one's got beef
sour cream this one seems to have more
beans and
cheese and stuff on it
okay wow oh wow i love her
wow i didn't even get time with her i
just discovered her now she's leaving
that's sad thinking you gotta go with
the nacho supreme on this one they're
both pretty
awesome i love taco bell beans yeah they
hurt my stomach for a little while but
gotta risk it for the biscuits sometimes
you know
[Music]
okay so she's a little lopsided i feel
like i've been doing super basic stuff
so i'm gonna add sauce to this one
because i don't know
she she looks like she needs it again
with the lettuce
[Music]
just lettuce doesn't taste like anything
like i don't understand
how people find lettuce appetizing i
don't even like salads with lettuce i
have to put spinach because spinach at
least tastes like dirt add that fire
sauce because you know
that chipotle sauce is out of this world
wow i love taco bell fiesta potatoes
wow i've never had fancy potatoes before
they're supposed to be like cheesy
fiesta potatoes
but um vegan so
like i mean they're just potatoes okay i
am
struggling here a bit i'm going to tag
team in roommate dan come in for a
second
ggps potatoes i always see this as an
option and i just never think to get it
until like afterwards i'm like you know
what that might sound really good bone
chase the first time that we got taco
bell together there wasn't a taco bell
in our area so we had to like go like at
least like i don't know
like 15 minutes away can you still talk
about that today
i mean i've been trying not to but you
got your boy giving me free taco bells
again
all right tonka potatoes
are just so good
like how are you getting rid of these i
wouldn't come to talk about for potatoes
but now i know
that they're really good but now they're
taking them away so
i'm full my stomach hurts i think i'm
gonna be in the bathroom
95 of today final thoughts are the beefy
frito burrito i'm sad to see it go it's
great
the spicy potato is amazing also
surprise winner this spicy tostada
incredible that chipotle sauce was
phenomenal i'm very sad that these items
are being taken away but you know
end of an era hopefully new things will
be able to come in and knowing taco bell
like
they're gonna come up with something if
you need to cry about it cry about it
if you need to go to taco bell and order
10 things and eat all of them in your
car alone and then like
do it you know
you